et
[Musique]
les shadoks notes sont débarqués sur la
terre pour charmer gêne avec leurs armes
musicales les jib yvon leur jouer un
tour avec leur petite boîte cosmique
les petites boîtes avaient été
soigneusement camouflés dans les
branches et les bosquets les petites
boîtes jb avec leur six côtés à
transformer les choses étaient vraiment
très amusante canton braquer le côté
lumière vers le soleil par exemple du
côté musique il sortait alors de la
musique soleil
[Musique]
si on le braquer sur des légumes verts
dans ce cas il sortait de la musique
carotte de la musique persil ou de la
musique haricots sans fil
[Musique]
et c'était réciproque si bien qu'on
rejoint de la musique haricots et même
en laissant le fils de l'autre côté on
récupère et devraient arriver et sans
fil mais les musiciens shadoks ne jouait
pas de cette musique là eux c'était bel
et bien de la musique
canon qui jouait de la musique cavalerie
de la musique d'assaut de la musique de
choc
[Musique]
en amour de la musique
lund et les petites boîtes djiby firent
leur fils
la musique derrière shadow qui leur
tournait sur la tête on lui fine ou par
paquet
[Musique]
il tirait une cannois musique et un
canot leurs tombes et aussi d'eau sur la
tête qui en a sommé du même coup une
bonne dizaine ils avançaient pour
attaquer ils se repliaient pour se
mettre un abri et sans retombées de plus
belle l'art des musicales décimée
jusqu'au dernier il ne restait plus un
gène qu'à ramasser les débris de
shadocks qui traînait et à les mettre en
garde de bourges gégène élégie be était
content il avait passé une bonne journée
ainsi se termine à la grande expédition
musicale shadoks sur la terre d'autres
descendre et ils ont encore de la lune
après ça
[Musique]